Sturme.
Dr. Tutro.
Okay, Herr Dr. Tutoglu.
Ja.
Wir sind in Deutschland, ne?
Ah ja.
Ahmet.
So.
Gibt es eine Wunschvorstellung?
Oder soll ich einfach loslegen?
Nein, einfach los.
Okay.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Ahmet Tutoglu.
Ich bin hier aus Asistan ausstattig.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahme-Schrift führen.
Bitte fragen Sie nach meiner Sicht etwas, nicht verstehen.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Stefan Wagner.
Stefan mit S-T-E-F-E-N.
S-T-E-F-E-N.
Stefan.
Und Wagner, W-A-G-N-E-R.
Wichtig.
Ja, richtig.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
35 Jahre alt.
35.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie denn noch geboren?
Am 11.1.1987.
11.1.1987.
87.
Okay.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
69 kg.
90.
9.
69.
960.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
Okay.
Ja, Herr Wagner, was fühlst Sie uns?
Und zwar folgendes.
Am letzten Wochenende, vor drei Tagen,
habe ich meinen Freund beim Umzug geholfen.
Wir mussten viele Pakete schleppen.
Und seit gestern,
oder vorgestern, Entschuldigung,
ein Tag danach,
seitdem habe ich Schmerzen in meiner rechten Schulter.
Und die haben wir zugenommen in den zwei Tagen.
Und ich kann meinen rechten Arm nicht hochheben.
Ich habe starken Schmerzen.
Bitte helfen Sie mir.
Was habe ich da?
Okay.
Wie stark sind Sie?
Zum Beispiel eine Schmerzskala 1,
eine Schmerzskala 2,
eine Schmerzskala 3,
eine Schmerzskala 1,
sehr lang sind Sie stark entspricht.
Entspricht sehr stark, Schmerzen, meinen Sie?
Also ich würde sagen,
aktuell ist es 8.
8,10 m.
Wenn ich meinen Arm hochhebe,
wenn ich nicht bewege, tut es leicht weh.
Okay.
Sie können Ihre Arm nicht heben, oder?
Genau, mein Arm kann ich ein bisschen hochheben,
aber nicht komplett.
Nicht komplett.
Also sobald ich etwa 50 Grad hochhebe,
dann habe ich starken Schmerzen.
Dann kann ich nicht mehr hochheben.
Ich muss meinen anderen Arm unterstützen,
und dann kann ich dann mehr hochheben.
Okay.
Ich trage den Schmerz in irgendein Wohin aus?
Ja, in meinen Oberarm.
Ja, Kartons, sehr schwer waren die Richter,
wir haben sehr viel geschleppt,
da waren manchmal leichte Sachen dabei,
manche schweren Sachen dabei,
musste helfen, wollte helfen.
Okay.
Ja.
Okay Herr Wagner,
ich möchte einige Fragen zu Ihrer allgemeinströmung,
stellen.
Ja, haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber, nein, habe ich nichts.
Okay.
Haben Sie Hüsten?
Hab ich nichts.
Okay.
Wie sieht es mit dem Wasser lassen?
Normal.
Stullgang.
Ist auch normal.
Okay.
Haben Sie starke Durst bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Das ist gut.
Okay, was lassen Stullgang?
Ja, wie ist es mit dem Wasser lassen?
Normal.
Stullgang.
Ist auch normal.
Okay.
Wie ist die Appetit?
Normal.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie wichtige Vorarlanker, zum Beispiel
Zuckerkrankheit oder Bulutochtur?
Nein.
Okay.
Nur dann Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, wo ich 10 Jahre alt war, wurde ich am Blind am operiert.
Okay.
Gibt es weitere Operationen?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gemacht?
Unfall gehabt, wann meint ihr jetzt?
Ab wocheneinander nein.
Aber früher.
Früher ja.
Ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente regelmäßig.
Und zum Beispiel Schmerzmittel oder
Berührungsmittel oder andere.
Nein.
Jetzt habe ich in den 2 Tagen, habe ich
Übeprofen eingenommen.
Für diese Schmerzen?
Ja, genau.
War das hilfreich?
Ja, die Schmerzen waren gelindert.
waren weniger.
Okay.
Wie viel Milligramm habe ich genommen?
Hab ich von meinem Freund bekommen, der hatte 800 Milligramm gehabt.
Da habe ich paar Stück genommen.
800 Milligramm.
Bye Bedarf habe ich genommen.
Bye Bedarf.
Okay.
Hab ich andere Dinge,
grobiert zum Beispiel eine Warmekistin oder
eine andere Form.
Ich habe etwas zugekühlt, aber es hat nicht viel gebracht.
Nach der Kühlung,
haben Sie einen starken Schmerz?
Nein, ich habe starken Schmerzen,
aber es hat nicht viel gebracht.
Das Kühlen war egal, ob ich es mitgekühlt habe.
Nicht hilfreich.
War nicht hilfreich?
Okay, dann. Okay, Sie haben keine regelmäßig Medikamente außer diese.
Im Profil? Nein.
Ja. Okay. Haben Sie Allergien?
Allergien, nicht, dass ich wüsste, nicht bekannt.
Okay, zum Beispiel gegen Gräße oder Polen oder...
Also ja, Polenallergie habe ich ja. Also Medikamente jetzt nicht, aber Polenallergie schon, ja.
Polenallergie. Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Meine Augen jucken und meine Nase läuft.
Geht zu und läuft.
Nase läuft. Okay.
Vertraue Sie alle Lebensmittel mit zum Beispiel Gluten oder Laktöse oder Fruktösen?
Du weißt, ich weiß, habe ich keine Probleme mit Lebensmittel.
Okay. Gut. Herr Wagner, jetzt kommen wir ihre Familie.
Wie haben Sie gesagt, ihre Familie?
Meine Name, Sie haben gesagt, her.
Herr Wagner. Wagner, ja. Entschuldigung, ich habe es falsch ausgehört.
Ah, okay. Sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder?
Die leben gesund, ja, aber die nehmen natürlich Medikamente ein.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen. Mein Papa nimmt irgendwas ein wegen seinem Bluthoffdruck.
Okay.
Und meine Mutter nimmt irgendeine Tablette ein wegen Zuckerkrankung.
Und sie ist halt ein bisschen übergewichtig.
Okay, übergewichtig.
Okay.
Hab ich einen Bruder?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Okay. Ist er gesund oder?
Ja, der ist gesund. Also, soweit ich weiß, ja, der nimmt keine Medikamente ein oder?
Okay. Hab ich einen Kind?
Ne, ich bin ledig.
Du bist ledig, okay.
Hab ich einen Freund?
Okay. Leben Sie mit Ihrer Freundin oder?
Ja, wir leben zusammen seit 10 Jahren.
Seit 10 Jahren, okay.
Ja, Herr Wagner, kommen wir jetzt Ihre Jawohlheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Rauchen, ja, kann man schon sagen.
Mit langsamem Teuer heutzutage, aber leider rauchig.
Okay, wie viele Reuten rauchen Sie?
Ja, so eine Packung kann man schon sagen, eine Packung pro Tag.
Seit wann?
Seit 15 Jahren.
15 Jahren, okay.
Wie viele Reuten haben Sie?
Alkohol, nicht regelmäßig.
Wenn irgendein Beobachtungszeichen von jemandem unregelmäßig ist.
Bei Gelegenheit trinke ich Alkohol.
Nicht regelmäßig.
Bier?
Ja, auch nicht.
Regelmäßig.
Wenn ein Fußballspiel, gucke ich mir keinen Fußball-Fan,
wenn ich Freunden oder Geburtstag ist.
Aber ich trinke Alkohol, nicht regelmäßig.
Das bedeutet, Sie trinken in einer Woche zum Beispiel ein oder nicht?
Oder in einer Woche, ja, ein Monat?
Ja, in einem Monat trinke ich vielleicht 2 Bier und Glas.
Das heißt, in 2-3 Wochen nicht,
weil die Leute Geburtstag haben.
Ja, in 2-3 Wochen trinke ich dann,
weil ich dann einen
Geburtstag habe.
Wir haben nicht wie eine Uhr, jede Woche Geburtstag,
sondern wenn da keine Geburtstag oder keine Feier ist,
dann trinke ich in dem Monat auch kein Alkohol.
Aber es ist mal Feier, dann geht man zur Party,
manche geht man zur Disco, oder was weiß ich.
Und dann trinkt man halt und ich würde sagen,
durchschnittlich 2 Bier im Monat
und durchschnittlich vielleicht insgesamt gesehen,
halbe Liter Whiskey.
Okay, alles klar.
Aber ich würde dir sagen, ich trinke auf einmal Whiskey.
Dann bin ich.
Okay, Herr Wagner, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht überall,
aber haben Sie Drogen probiert?
Nein, ich habe nichts damit zu tun.
Okay, gut.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie sind ledig,
haben keine Kinder und leben mit Ihrer Freundin.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Kfz-Mechaniker, ich repariere Autos.
Kfz-Mechaniker.
Okay.
Sind Sie zufrieden mit Ihrer Arbeit?
Ja.
Und mit Ihrer Freundin?
Okay, gut.
Herr Wagner, ich möchte eine Sammelfassung machen.
Sie sind 35 Jahre alt
und nach dem Umzug aufgetretene Rechte schültern
und haben Schmerzen.
Sie haben Schmerzen ausgestrahlt in den Oberarm.
Die Schmerzen rüber haben ausgestrahlt.
Ja.
Sie haben ihr Prof. genannt,
aber sie gekürt und aber diese
Prozedur nicht hilfreich.
Okay.
Okay, oder? Möchten Sie,
irgendwelche Dinge hinzufügen, oder?
Von meiner Seite aus, nicht.
Okay.
Von Ihrer Seite aus, weiß ich nicht.
Gibt es Schwellungen in diesem Schultern?
In der rechten Schulterstellung? Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Oder? Wärmung?
Überwärmung? Nein, also wenn ich mit meiner Hand hinfasse,
ist es nicht warm.
Okay, keine Schwellungen, keine Überwärmung.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe meine wichtige Fragen gestartet.
Und jetzt möchte ich Sie untersuchen.
Okay, gerne.
Hat jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen in der Gruppe?
Nein.
Ich habe auch noch eine Frage.
Also ich habe das Thema.
Ich habe auch noch ein Frage in der Gruppe.
Ja, also ich habe eine Frage in der Gruppe.
Was wissen Sie, wie Sie sich mit dem Omuzlalbalkal anschauen?
Ja, wie Sie sich mit dem Omuzlalbalkal anschauen.
Nach dem Unsuch auf getretene Breite Schulter Schmerzen.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Seit zwei Tagen, ja.
Okay, Nummer eins.
Was wissen Sie noch?
Schmerzkala, wissen Sie?
Ja, ich habe Schmerzkala, 8 von 10.
Und ich habe das gefragt.
Und ich habe Schwöllungen und Überbärmung gefragt.
Sie haben gekühlt und über Profen genommen.
Und dann, dieser war nicht hilfreich.
Über Profen schon?
Über Profen schon, aber können nicht.
Ja.
Ich würde sagen, ich erkläre es andersherum.
In der Orthopädie oder Unfallstierungen, in der Notfallambulanz, wenn man einen Brief schreibt,
dann einen schnellen Ambulanzbrief, da kommt immer der Satz.
Die perifere Durchflutung motorisch sensibilität ist intakt.
Das kann man als Hilfe nehmen, als Gedankenstütze.
Das heißt, Durchflutung kann man an einem Nese fragen, das ist schwierig,
weil sie nicht Gefäße tasten können.
Oder Arterialderesputz, aber man kann fragen, gibt es einen Temperaturunterschied zwischen den Rechten und linken Arm?
Zum Beispiel.
Als Sensibilitätstörung haben Sie Missempfindungen, kippeln Taubheitsgefühl, als neurologische Frage?
Aber ich dachte normalerweise, mit dieser Stoßion, nicht wichtig gefunden.
Da stimmt schon für den schnellen Blick, aber Sie sind vielleicht nicht der Oberarzt, der dann sagt, das brauche ich alles nicht.
Sie sind der Assistenzarzt und Sie brauchen für Ihre Prüfung eine bestimmte Zeit.
Sie müssen ja, wenn Sie in 2 Minuten, 5 Minuten fertig sind, Sie müssen 20 Minuten mit denen reden.
Dann kriegen Sie viele Fragen.
Okay, Sie haben recht.
Und, was man neurologisch fragen kann, ob eine Parise war, eine Lehmung des Armes.
Er kann den bewegen, aber er hat keine Lehmung zum Beispiel, eine Paristisie zum Beispiel.
Er hat mir spätstbedingt, kann er den Arm nicht hochheben.
Wir hatten vorhin gesagt, dass er den Arm etwa bis 40 Grad anheben kann.
Also ist die Motorik noch da.
Können Sie die Hand auf und zu machen, eine Faust machen, Finger bewegen? Ja.
Also ist die Peripferde durch Blutung Motorik sensibilitätintakt zum Beispiel.
Da kann man anhand das hier, kann man dann dran.
Und idealerweise wäre, wie Sie am Anfang erst begonnen haben,
was führt Sie zu uns?
Und dann die spezielle Anamese, alles, was mit Schulter zu tun hat.
Und dann den Rest, egal wie Sie das machen.
Und dass man so eine Struktur hat, dass man alle Fragen stellt.
Und dann versucht, einen Leitfaden zu nehmen, wie ich das vertreib.
Oder wie ich das jetzt erkennen, dass ich das habe, kurz an das.
Wenn ich das auch wieder bewegen würde, das war schon hier, das war schon hier.
Was für mich?
Das war für mich einfach.
Es war viel zu schnell.
Wenn du das nicht sagst understand das alles.
Das ist empezallend.
Und abends dann, das war für mich einfach.
Und das war, das war für mich einfach.
Ja, es geht ja nicht darum, wie der Fall einfach richtig ist, aber es geht ja bei euch nicht zu gut.
Ja, natürlich. Und diese, ja, manchmal kann blind sein, man.
Man kann.
Ja.
Irgendjemand hat in der Gruppe geschrieben, Autobäde, Analyse, Tech, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, habe ich nicht gelesen können.
Egal, Technisch wahrscheinlich. Ja, wir Autobäden sind Handwerker. Wir philosophieren nicht, wir arbeiten.
Funktionale Analyse.
Generell, man hat auch sehr gut.
Generell, man hat gesagt, ich bin im Zeitpunkt, wie ich das sagen kann.
10 Jahre vor allem, als ich war, dann kamen viele Menschen aus dem Land.
Ich habe mich auch sehr gut gemacht.
Dankeschön.
Ja, nächste Woche habe ich Gruffungen.
Ja, okay, ne Guter Ist der. Es gibt ein deutscher Sprichwort.
Übung, Martin Meister.
Ah, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Alles klar. Wollen wir dann eine, guten Abend, mein Name ist Kosar.
Ich bin der Unsoberarzt hier.
Okay.
Wenn keine Fragen sind in der Gruppe, dann können wir dann loslegen.
Guten Tag Oberarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie es seid?
Ja, gerne.
Deswegen bin ich da.
Sie sind los.
Okay.
Herr Stefan Wagner, 35 Jahre alt, 69 kg, 178 cm.
Haben Sie uns seit zwei Tagen aufgetretene rechte Schulterschmerzen?
Diese Schmerzen waren auf einer Schmerzkala 8 von 10.
Unsere Patient könne rechte Schulter nicht gut bewegen, nicht gut heben.
Und außerdem habe Patienten keine Lernungen, Patienten keine Lernungen und keine Temperatur
unterschied.
Temperatur unterschied, wie meinen Sie das?
Beide Armen haben gleich Temperatur.
Deswegen haben Sie das erwähnt, um etwas auszuschließen?
Patient erwähnt das.
Wir haben z.B. TVT ausgeschlossen oder Artilietrombas ausgeschlossen.
Sie haben ein Gefäß Durchspritungsproblem.
Sie wollten darauf hinweisen, ob ein Durchspritungsproblem besteht.
Das besteht keine Durchspritungsprobleme.
Für diese Schmerzen haben die Patienten über Profen 800 mg genommen und es war hilfreich.
Die Kühlung war nicht hilfreich.
Die vegetative Anemle war unaufwändig.
Die Vorerkrankung war unaufwändig bis auf der Appendectomy.
Die Patient hat allergegegen Polen.
Die Familienanamnese ergab Artilielle Hypertonie und Adipositas beim Vater, Diabetes mellitus
und Adipistos auch bei der Mutter.
Die Noxenanamnese ergab 15 Pakze und unsere Patienten nehmen untergelmäß Alkohol,
Zweibeer oder Halbliter Whiskey im Monat z.B.
Er ist schließlich erledigt und lebt mit seinen Freunden,
Arbeiter als Karabizettmechaniker.
Aufgrund der erwähnten Angräben gehe ich von einer Verdachtdiagnose auf Supraspinatus Tendinitis.
Alternativ kommt Supraspinatus Ris, Darupter
oder aufgrund der erwähnten Abklärung,
nach der körperlichen Untersuchung,
abgenommen werden, aufgrund der Aufnahme gemacht werden.
Es geht um die Differenzialdiagnose,
die Supraspinatus-Szene gerissen oder entzündet wäre.
die Supraspinatus-Szene gerissen oder entzündet werden.
Es geht um die Differenzialdiagnose, die Supraspinatus-Szene gerissen oder entzündet werden.
Sie haben eine Röntgen veranlasst.
Hat der Patient, der bei dem Umzug geholfen hat, geholfen oder einen Trauma bekannt?
Nein, ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Der hatte keine Trauma gehabt.
Wenn man keine Trauma hat, warum machen Sie einen Röntgen?
Der ist 35 Jahre alt und ist aus dem Brust.
Aber was wollen Sie dort feststellen?
Ein Bruch oder eine Subluxation auszuschließen.
Aber wenn man die Tendinitis Calcarea hat, kann man etwas darstellen?
Ja, Sie haben recht. Aber eine Tendinitis Calcarea ist eine chronische Erkrankung.
Sie wissen ja nicht, als Kapitän mechatika vielleicht hat er viel gearbeitet.
Ein Büro-Mensch kann auch in den Hobby-Bereich viel arbeiten.
Sie sind ja vielleicht der Türkei Facharzt, aber hier sind Sie als Tendz-Arzt.
Deswegen müssen Sie alles denken.
Oder was man noch sehen kann, Arthrose.
Im Pinchment.
Also ob die Einigung der Hymeroskopf-Hochstand ist.
Was kann man wahrscheinlich bei dem Jungen machen?
Denken wir mal, wir schließen alles aus.
Als weitere Verfahren. Diagnostik, was würden Sie doch machen?
Außer Röntgen? Was könnte man noch machen?
Wir können Ultraschall machen.
Mit Ultraschall können wir Tendinitis gut oder Muskelrisse sehen.
Nicht alles, aber z.B. mit Pytanos.
Den Ansatz von den Sehnen können Sie gucken, ob da ein Risksvorhanden ist
oder eine Tendinopathie davon ist.
Was könnte man noch für eine Diagnostik machen?
Wir können MRT machen.
Eine letzte Frage wegen der Diagnostik.
Wenn Sie zum Radiologen einen Röntgenauftrag schicken.
Wie heißt dieser Auftrag?
Schreiben Sie da drauf.
Röntgen Sie bitte das Schulter?
Röntgen Schulter in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen Schulter rechts oder rechte Schulter in zwei Ebenen.
Nicht ins Rümmer und Akknaus.
Ich werde ein Röntgen anfordern.
Röntgen Schulter in zwei Ebenen.
Fuß in zwei Ebenen.
Schrunggelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Kniegelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Röntgen Schulter rechts und rechte Schulter in zwei Ebenen.
Wenn Sie sich verhindern können,
wir können den Patienten selbst helfen.
Was würden Sie jetzt den Patienten empfehlen? Wir haben keinen Frachtur gesehen, MRT haben wir
jetzt nicht gemacht, Ultraschall haben wir gemacht und wir haben keinen Risiko gesehen. Und die Diagnose,
sagen wir mal, das ist dann eine Tendinitis der Supraspinatus-Szene und eine Buritis,
superkrummel alles. Was würde Ihnen für den Patienten empfehlen? Normalerweise empfehle ich
eine Facharztuntersuchung, als ist das hier orthopädische Untersuchung. Und aber im Praxis,
zum Beispiel, ich schreibe ein Nichtsteroidal Antiromatismal oder Nichtsteroidal Antiromatika,
nicht so Antiromatika und außerdem empfehle ich Erwärmung und vermeiden nicht,
ich werde Dinge zuheben oder schieben. Ich empfehle dieses als erstes und dann, wenn geht
weiter und dann mehr Schmerzen haben, dann Krakringymnastik auch und physikalische Therapie.
Und wenn die Beschwerden weiter bestehen, kann man auch einen MRT im Verlauf empfehlen.
Ja, natürlich. Weil MRT den Krankenhäuser macht man in der Regel nicht schnell. Die Realität ist,
Ultraschall macht man auch nicht meistens, es wird gerünscht und MRT wird für den Niedergelassenen,
der in der Praxis hat empfohlen, zum Beispiel Beschwerde-Presidents MRT empfohlen.
NSAR kann man geben, in den Kliniken gibt man nicht, vorhin hat eine Kollegin geschrieben,
Kollege oder Kollegin geschrieben, Injektion zum Beispiel, kontasonhaltige, kristallinhaltige
Kontason mit 3 Amtschulonsen, zum Beispiel, kann man mit lokalen Ästhetikum applizieren
oder spritzen, injetzieren, aber in den Krankenhäusern machen die das nicht.
Also wenn sie, warum? Weil sehr viele Patienten da sind und Superprogramme, Rejektion,
kann man machen, aber das wird der niedergelassenen Kollege. Sie sind ja in der Notfallambulanz,
ja natürlich. Wenn sie in der Praxis sind, dann würde ich bei so stark, ich persönlich,
als erstes empfehlen, weil der Armlich-Hochteam angehoben werden kann, also sind Schwerstaben
Schmerzen und Lebensqualität-Einschränkung, wenn man kann nicht eine Haare waschen oder andere
Sachen. Deswegen würde ich direkt empfehlen, dass man eine Injektion mit Cortison macht,
Superchromial und ich mache auch Intratocular, weil Intratocular, ich habe das Cortison überall
hin, plus Superchromial, dann die Bursa auch Superchromial, also Erzünungshämmer hat,
dann würde ich sagen nicht NSAR bei Bedarf, sondern regelmäßig, bei Ibuprofen 3 mal am Tag
für 3 bis 5 Tage einnehmen. Kühlung an der Laterale Seite, aber oben am Schulterblatt, wo Muskel
ist, kann man Wärme machen. Ansonsten würde ich dann sagen, also in der Praxis würde ich
dann sagen, wenn die Schmerzen noch bei denen bestehen, nach einer Woche kommen sie dann
vorbei, dann würde man MRT vielleicht durchschüllen lassen. In der Praxis, in der Klinik,
Realität ist, Patienten kommen, sie untersuchen und machen einen Röntgen, schließen eine
Fraktur aus, Arthrose, Arthvedoratrose, geben dann halt ein NSAR, vielleicht doch ein zweites
Analgetiker wie Novalgin oder Thylidin noch zusätzlich und sagen dann, wenn es nicht besser
wird, gehen sie morgen zum Orthopäden zum Beispiel. Realität ist, morgen kriegt er
kein Termin, das ist komische Sache in Deutschland, ist nicht so, dass man schnell ein orthopädes
Termin bekommt, aber dann wird man ein Kranbraus als Sahn, das ist keine hochakute Sache und tschüss.